out through his golden doors Donald J
Trump his body language on the face of
it defiance
America's 45th president but the first
to face A Moment Like This
from every angle history recorded the
Convoy to bring a president from his
Penthouse to the dock
and so here it is a Journey Begins a
president goes to court
and as the Convoy headed south through
Manhattan he was of course online this
time with words that reflect the moment
well perfectly so surreal he wrote from
the car wow they're going to arrest me
can't believe this is happening in
America but so it did
50 or so blocks south a wave and then
steps into the history books steps that
no American president has taken before
away from the cameras he was
fingerprinted but not handcuffed and no
mug shot and then into the courtroom
we even speak to US president Trump
inside video banned but the images tell
the story flanked by his defense team
Donald Trump listened to the charges
against him 34 counts 16 pages and three
different instances where he is accused
of paying money to keep people quiet not
guilty he pleaded outside the world
absorbed the charges unsealed for the
first time among them cash for a Trump
Tower doorman relating to a child born
out of wedlock cash for a woman who
claimed she'd had sex with the president
and that money for Stormy Daniels the
porn star paid off just days before he
won the election in 2016.
the president departed with no words
they were left for his lawyers a team
who now know the details of the case
they say they will fight today's
unsealing of this indictment shows that
the rule of law died in this country
because well everyone is not above the
law no one's below it either and if this
man's name was not Donald J Trump there
is no scenario we'd all be here today
please understand that based on these
charges
over the road in the park all the
president's supporters led by
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene
and drowned out by the other side a
snapshot of the division that comes with
every twist in the Trump story
it's unprecedented
they say what he did was illegal
Deport him all the way I
see it
too crazy what are you making What's
Happening Here I think it's the greatest
thing that happened he deserves it it's
about time to sucker got caught I don't
think the president's above the law but
I think that if you look at the evidence
president Trump did nothing wrong and
the situation is the Witch Hunt thank
you
leading the establishment Witch Hunt
they allege Alvin Bragg the district
attorney whose sights have always been
on Mr Trump he had his moment
34 false statements
made to cover up other crimes
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conducts
a day of History written and so much
more to come the former president the
man who could still be again was off
back to Florida and Mar-A-Lago Mark
Stone Sky News in New York